akármilyen jó indulattal is nyúlnánk
hozzá magához a házasság intézményéhez
akkor is a következménye halál ez mit
jelent én számomra ez most azt jelenti
hogy az elmúlt évtizedekben európa és a
nyugati világ folyamatosan játszott a
házasság gondolatával hogy hol lehetne
egy picit torzítani hogy minél inkább
befogadóbb legyen hogy minél hogy hogy
hogy hogy ne csak férfi és nő között
legyen házasság és hogy hogy konkrétan
mit is ismerünk el házasságnak és hogy
hogy állatokkal lehet-e házasodni
például és
ah ha elkezdünk játszani a szent
dolgokkal akkor a következménye halál ez
például megjelenik a szaporulati
indexben hogy hogy a nyugati világ
szaporulati indexe az az önfenntartás
alatt van lassan elpusztul a nyugati
világ ez ilyen szempontból is megjelenik
de megjelenik a hétköznapokban is amikor
valaki valaki életellenesen kezdi élni
az életét önmagát pusztítva olyan
kapcsolatokba belelépve ahol inkább
deger álódik a a személyisége mint az
hogy fejlődjön
úgyhogy ezt így megértve az elmúlt
években én is azt látom hogy házasság
valóban szent hogy nekem is feladatom az
hogy alázatosan megértsem hogy miért
szent